This is 99% Invisible. I'm Vivian Le, sitting in for Roman Mars. I've lived in Los Angeles for give or take eight years now, and I wanted to take you to a place here in the city that's a little weird, but also pretty special. Maybe it's a different spot that we get in. I feel like this is going to be a lot of guess and check. It's also kind of hard to get into. Luckily, I had backup with me. This street that we're on is about as close as you can get to the river.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le），替罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）主持。我在洛杉矶住了差不多八年，我想带大家去城里一个有点怪异却又相当特别的地方。也许我们进的是另一个地方。我觉得这需要不断摸索尝试。而且这里其实挺难进去的。幸运的是，我有同伴支援。我们现在这条街，离河道已经非常近了。
I know that there is some way to get down there, like an access tunnel point, which I don't know what your appetite is for getting into a tunnel. Reporting the story with me this week is Gillian Jacobs. Gillian is an actor, a director, and of course, a fellow LA resident. Yes, and that elusive spot we were trying to get to was the LA River. There it is. There's the river. There's our guy.
我知道肯定有办法下去，比如某个检修通道口，不过我不知道你对钻隧道有多大兴趣。本周和我一起做这篇报道的是吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）。吉莉安是一位演员、导演，当然，也是一位洛杉矶老居民。没错，我们之前极力想要抵达的那个难找的地方就是洛杉矶河。那就是。河就在那儿。我们的向导也在那儿。
What is the predominant emotion you're feeling right now? Aw. It's a lie. When you hear the word river, you probably picture a majestic body of water flowing through a natural habitat. Well, the L.A. River looks nothing like that. Most people who see it probably mistake it for a giant storm drain. It's a deep trapezoidal channel with steep concrete walls and a flat concrete bottom. In the spot we were at, the riverbanks were lined with railroad
你现在内心最主要的感受是什么？啊。这不对劲。当你听到“河流”这个词时，你脑海中浮现的可能是一条在自然环境中流淌的雄伟水系。然而，洛杉矶河看起来完全不是那回事。大多数看到它的人，大概都会把它误认为是一个巨大的暴雨排水沟。这是一条深邃的梯形河道，有着陡峭的混凝土堤岸和扁平的混凝土河底。在我们去的那地方，河岸边排列着铁路
tracks, industrial warehouses, and commuter traffic. The water part of it, as in the thing that rivers are most known for having exists as just a tiny stream at the bottom of the concrete for most of the year. I mean, it is quite ugly. It's very ugly right here. But it is kind of pretty in a weird way. And there's water flowing, but it's like algae. The LA River is a surreal place to be,
轨道、工业仓库和通勤车流。至于水本身——也就是河流最广为人知的特征——在一年中的大部分时间里，只在混凝土河底汇成了一道细小的水流。我的意思是，它确实挺难看的。这地方看起来非常丑。但在某种诡异的层面上，它又有点好看。有水在流淌，但看起来像藻类。洛杉矶河是一个充满超现实感的地方，
which has made it a great location to have edgy photo shoots or film movies. You've actually probably seen it in the iconic scene from Grease where the T-birds drag race the scorpions down the dry riverbed, or the scene from Terminator 2 where the T-1000 chases John Connor in a semi-truck. Yes, Los Angeles is a modern city filled with concrete, but other major cities with rivers like Chicago, London, and Paris have managed to retain more
这使得它成了拍摄前卫时尚大片或电影的绝佳取景地。你实际上很可能在《油脂》（Grease）的经典场景中见过它——当年T-鸟帮（T-birds）开着车在干涸的河床里和蝎子帮（Scorpions）飙车，或者在《终结者2》（Terminator 2）里，T-1000驾驶着半挂卡车追杀约翰·康纳（John Connor）。没错，洛杉矶是一座充满混凝土的现代大都会，但其他拥有河流的大城市，比如芝加哥、伦敦和帕，都设法保留了更多
of the natural river-ness. Those rivers feel untouched in comparison to the hyper-engineered Los Angeles River. Los Angeles was founded around this river, but decades ago, it was confined in concrete so that, for better or worse, the city could become the sprawling metropolis that it is today. And all these years later, we are still grappling with the consequences of those actions.
原汁原味的河流特质。相比之下，那些河流显得未经雕琢，而洛杉矶河则经过了过度工程改造。洛杉矶就是围绕这条河建立起来的，但在几十年前，它被限制在混凝土构筑物中，无论好坏，这座城市才得以演变成今天这样不断蔓延的大都市。而多年后的今天，我们依然在艰难应对这些行为带来的后果。
Before the river was encased in a narrow concrete passageway, it wandered freely throughout the Los Angeles basin. Think of water everywhere. There were rivulets, there were freshets, you know, little stream beds that you had to leap across all over Southern California, all the way up to Beverly Hills they found these little watercourses and it's almost impossible to imagine that Los Angeles. This is Pat Morrison, LA Times columnist and author of the book Rio LA. She says that even before human intervention, the LA River behaved in peculiar ways. After heavy rains, the LA River would swell from a trickle into a full-blown river,
在河流被包裹进狭窄的混凝土通道之前，它在洛杉矶盆地中自由流淌。想象一下到处都是水。到处都是小溪、支流，你知道的，在南加州到处都是那种你得跳过去的小溪床，一直延伸到贝弗利山庄，人们都能发现这些小水流，而要想象那时的洛杉矶几乎是不可能的。这位是帕特·莫里森（Pat Morrison），《洛杉矶时报》专栏作家，《里约洛杉矶》（Rio LA）一书的作者。她说，甚至在人类干预之前，洛杉矶河的表现就很奇特。大雨过后，洛杉矶河会从涓涓细流膨胀成一条真正的河流，
but with no fixed course. Sometimes when the river flooded, it would cut new pathways, turning different parts of the LA basin into a tapestry of wetlands and inland seas. It may rain for two or three months out of the year, and what that rain does constitutes pretty much where the river decides to go. If it's not a very rainy season, the river will behave itself in its pretty, you know, small, flat little bed. But if there's a lot of rain, it's going to say, well, this looks like a good place to flood, and this looks like a good place to overflow.
但没有固定的河道。有时河水泛滥时，它会冲刷出新的路径，将洛杉矶盆地的不同地区变成一片由湿地和内陆海交织而成的挂毯。一年中可能会下两三个月雨，而这场雨大致决定了河水最终流向何方。如果不是雨水很多的季节，河水就会安分地待在它那漂亮、狭窄、平坦的小河床里。但如果雨水充沛，它就会说，嗯，这里看起来是个泛滥的好地方，那里看起来是个漫滩的好地方。
The river's watershed was larger than the island of Maui. And all of this untethered water had a huge impact on the entire ecosystem of Los Angeles. People today look at LA and think it's a desert because it's so dry. But the climate is actually closer to the kind of Mediterranean weather you'd see in, say, Spain or Portugal.
这条河的流域面积比毛伊岛还要大。所有这些不受束缚的水对洛杉矶的整个生态系统产生了巨大影响。如今人们看着洛杉矶，觉得这里是个沙漠，因为它太干燥了。但这里的气候实际上更接近你在西班牙或葡萄牙等地看到的典型地中海气候。
The river supported dense forests, marshlands, and enormous biodiversity. So the river did not just affect the corridor that it runs in. It affected the whole landscape. This is Matthew Tutimas, tribal biologist for the Gabrielino Band of Mission Indians Keech Nation. Tutimas says that the Keech built their lives around the water provided by the LA River.
这条河曾经滋养了茂密的森林、沼泽地和极其丰富的生物多样性。所以这条河不仅影响了它所流经的走廊地带。它影响了整个景观。这位是马修·图蒂马斯（Matthew Tutimas），加布里埃利诺部落印第安人基奇族（Gabrielino Band of Mission Indians Keech Nation）的部落生物学家。图蒂马斯说，基奇族人的生活正是围绕着洛杉矶河所提供的水源构建的。
Now, the LA River, the ancient name for it is Wienot, which means the life-giver. And that pretty much explains it all in terms of the capacity of what this river provided. Even in its original natural state, the LA River was very boom or bust. During the rainy season, the river would flood wide swaths of the LA Basin. But during the dry season, which in LA is most of the year, most of the rushing surface water would shrink to a shallow stream. Many of our zones and many of our waterways are ephemeral, meaning they're seasonal. They only occur during high water volume times. Despite these patterns of flooding and drought, the river was more than enough to support
现在，洛杉矶河的古称是维诺特（Wienot），意思是“生命之源”。这几乎完美地诠释了这条河所提供的巨大容量。即使在其原始的自然状态下，洛杉矶河也是一条极度大起大落的河流。在雨季，河水会淹没洛杉矶盆地的广阔区域；但在旱季——在洛杉矶，一年中的大部分时间都是旱季——汹涌的地表水大部分都会缩减为一条浅浅的小溪。我们的许多地带和许多水道都是季节性的，这意味着它们只出现在水量充沛的时期。尽管有这种洪水和干旱交替的规律，这条河依然完全足以支撑
the indigenous communities of the LA basin. That is until, of course, the arrival of European colonizers. Los Angeles fell under the control of Spain, then Mexico, then finally the United States. And to settlers from the East Coast, the LA River, which seemed both too wet and too dry, was baffling. Yankee rivers earn their keep. Yankee rivers are rivers where you can float barges and move goods and commerce and people. And what kind of lazy-ass river just sits around and doesn't do anything for nine months out of the year?
洛杉矶盆地的原住民社区。当然，直到欧洲殖民者到来。洛杉矶先后落入西班牙、墨西哥的控制之下，最后归属美国。对于来自东海岸的定居者来说，洛杉矶河既显得太湿又显得太干，简直让人摸不着头脑。洋基队的河流能够自食其力。洋基河流是可以用来浮载驳船、运输货物、商业和人员的河流。而这到底是什么懒散透顶的河流，一年中有九个月什么都不干，就这么闲坐着呢？
So it was a very frustrating river for people who came with these industrial sensibilities to look at and to depend on. When California gained statehood in 1850, the population of Los Angeles absolutely exploded. The city grew from just under 2,000 to 100,000 people in only 50 years. This growing population began depleting the river and its groundwater to the point that by the turn of the 20th century, the LA River was completely dry. But Los Angeles city leaders had no intention
因此，对于带着这种工业化思维来看待它、依赖它的人们来说，这是一条非常令人沮丧的河流。1850年加利福尼亚获得州地位时，洛杉矶的人口彻底爆发了。仅仅50年里，城市人口就从不到2000人激增到10万人。不断增长的人口开始过度消耗这条河及其地下水，以至于到20世纪之交时，洛杉矶河已经彻底干涸了。但洛杉矶的城市领导人根本不打算
of slowing the population growth because they wanted to become the dominant city in California. So instead, they found themselves a different water source. In 1913, a civil engineer named William Mulholland unveiled an aqueduct that diverted water from the Owens Valley about 233 miles north and siphoned it down to LA. The aqueduct basically destroyed the livelihood of farmers up north and set off a series of violent conflicts called the California Water Wars. Sorry, that last beat of LA history was a bit of a spoiler if you've never seen the movie
放缓人口增长的步伐，因为他们想成为加利福尼亚最具统治力的城市。于是，他们转而寻找了另一个水源。1913年，一位名叫威廉·穆赫兰（William Mulholland）的土木工程师揭幕了一条引水渠，将大约233英里以北欧文斯山谷（Owens Valley）的水引流并输送到洛杉矶。这条引水渠基本上毁掉了北方农民的生计，并引发了一系列被称为“加州水战”的暴力冲突。抱歉，如果你没看过电影
Chinatown. Once the dust had settled and Los Angeles had itself a shiny new imported water source, Angelinos pivoted from draining their river to outright trashing it. They dumped waste from factories, dead animals from slaughterhouses, and untreated sewage into the mostly dry riverbed. It was inconsequential as far as Angelino's were concerned by then. So to make room for the people and industries of a booming new city, developers built closer and closer to the dried up banks of the river.
《唐人街》（Chinatown），刚才那段关于洛杉矶历史的剧透可能有点扫兴。尘埃落定之后，洛杉矶拥有了光鲜亮丽的全新进口水源，洛杉矶人也从排干河水转向了彻底糟蹋河水。他们将工厂的废料、屠宰场的动物死尸以及未经处理的污水倾倒在基本干涸的河床里。对当时的洛杉矶人来说，这根本无足轻重。因此，为了给蓬勃发展的新城市的人口和工业腾出空间，开发商们越建越近，直逼干涸的河岸。
But of course, the LA River isn't just any kind of river. And all of this short-sighted development backfired in a big way. When these settlers came out here, their small timeframe of knowing how our land works, they said, eh, let's get close to the rivers. You know, we don't get much water anyway, and then we have our floods. Remember, the LA River could be dry for long stretches of time, and this was especially true after settlers depleted the watershed.
但当然，洛杉矶河可不是什么普通的河流。所有这种短视的开发最终产生了巨大的反效果。当这些定居者来到这里时，他们用自己对土地运作规律的短浅认知说：“哦，咱们靠近河流建房吧。反正也没多少水，偶尔发发洪水也没事。”记住，洛杉矶河可能会长时间保持干涸，在定居者耗尽流域水源之后，这种情况尤其明显。
But it was only a matter of time before Los Angeles had another big rainy season. To make matters worse, the topography of Los Angeles County was practically designed to flood. The principal city of Los Angeles sits in the bowl that's surrounded by the ocean and then by mountains and hills. And all of the rains that come to those areas over the course of a winter have nowhere to go except down. And we are down. That's where we are. What makes the LA River's flood path especially dangerous is just how quickly the water can move once it gets going. The watershed begins high up in the Santa Susana Mountains, the San Gabriel Mountains,
但洛杉矶迎来下一个大雨季只是时间问题。更糟糕的是，洛杉矶县的地形简直就是天生为了发洪水而设计的。洛杉矶的主城区位于一个盆地中，四周环海，又被山脉和丘陵包围。整个冬天降落在这些地区的雨水无处可去，只能往下流。而我们就在下游。这就是我们的位置。洛杉矶河的行洪路径之所以格外危险，是因为一旦水势形成，其流速之快简直惊人。流域发源于高处的圣苏珊娜山脉、圣加布里埃尔山脉
and the San Fernando Valley and drops to a very low altitude in the blink of an eye. — And because of the steep decline, that water picks up incredible speed. — Now, the Mississippi River and the LA River both drop about the same distance from source to mouth. The difference is the Mississippi River takes 2,000 miles to get from way up there to way down there. We do it in 50 miles. 50 miles.
和圣费尔南多谷，并在眨眼间骤降至极低的海拔。——由于坡度极陡，水流速度会快得惊人。——现在，密西西比河和洛杉矶河从源头到入海口的落差其实差不多。不同之处在于，密西西比河需要流经2000英里才能从那么高的地方流到那么低的地方。而我们只用了50英里。50英里。
So it's like the difference between a wheelchair ramp and a water slide. And it all comes down. And it brings it into this funnel all of the tributaries of the Los Angeles River and so when it rains a lot the water comes shooting down off of those hills like something crazy. In 1914, the year after the Owens Valley aqueduct opened, LA was hit with a major flood. It caused so much damage that there was a public outcry for the city to address its flooding problems. But did the people of Los
所以这就像是无障碍轮椅坡道和水上滑梯的区别。水流全倾泻而下。它把洛杉矶河的所有支流都汇集进这个漏斗里，因此每当大雨倾盆，水流就会像疯了一样从那些山丘上狂泻而下。1914年，即欧文斯山谷引水渠开通的次年，洛杉矶遭遇了一场大洪水。这场洪水造成了巨大的破坏，以至于公众强烈呼吁市政府解决水患问题。但是洛杉矶的人民
Angeles learn their lesson about building right up to the banks of the flood-prone river? No! That's right, Gillian. And 20 years later, in 1934, it happened again, only worse. In the last week of December in 1933, Los Angeles was slammed with a heavy winter storm, and on New Year's Day, the banks of the LA River swelled beyond their capacity. And Woody Guthrie wrote a song about the great Los Angeles flood. hit the mountains, it swept away our homes, and a hundred souls was taken in that fatal New Year's flood. This second flood gained national attention and prompted the federal government to step in.
吸取了不要在易涝河岸边建房的教训了吗？并没有！没错，吉莉安。20年后的1934年，悲剧重演，而且情况更糟。1933年12月的最后一周，洛杉矶遭到了一场猛烈冬季风暴的袭击，元旦那天，洛杉矶河的河岸暴涨，超出了承载极限。伍迪·格思里（Woody Guthrie）还为这场伟大的洛杉矶洪水写过一首歌。它袭击了山脉，冲毁了我们的家园，在那场致命的新元旦洪水中，有一百条生命消逝了。这场第二次洪水引起了全国关注，并促使联邦政府介入。
In 1936, Congress passed a law that gave the U.S. Army Corps of Engineers authority over the L.A. River to build flood control measures. But it was a third flood just a couple of years later that would lead to the river's downfall. 1938 was the flood that essentially doomed the Los Angeles River to no longer be a natural river. March 2, 1938 is, to this day, the wettest day on record for Los Angeles and led to the most devastating flood
1936年，国会通过了一项法律，赋予美国陆军工兵部队对洛杉矶河的管辖权，以便修建防洪工程。但仅仅几年后的第三场洪水，才最终导致了这条河的彻底覆灭。1938年的那场洪水，基本上注定了洛杉矶河不再是一条自然河流的命运。直到今天，1938年3月2日依然是洛杉矶有记录以来降雨量最大的一天，并引发了该市历史上最具毁灭性的洪水
in the city's history. In current day value, the flood caused about $1.7 billion worth of damage and an estimated 115 people were killed. Disaster, destruction and death descend on five Southern California counties. Tons of water submerged 30,000 square miles of populous beach. And in the 1938 flood, the prop department of Warner Brothers was very badly damaged by the rising river waters.
按今天的价值计算，这场洪水造成了约17亿美元的损失，估计有115人丧生。灾难、毁灭和死亡降临到南加州五个县。吨吨洪水淹没了3万平方英里的密集海滩。而在1938年的洪水中，华纳兄弟公司的道具部被上涨的河水严重毁坏。
One of the things that got carried away was a big plywood whale that had been used in a movie. And so for that one minute, there was a whale in the Los Angeles River, even though it was a plywood movie whale, which sums up Los Angeles so beautifully. This third flood also brought the city's biggest event of the year to a standstill. This was in March of 1938. What happens in March, or usually did, the Oscars. They could not get to the Oscars. Now we're talking crisis. Three days they had to postpone the Oscars because the movie stars were stranded. That was the final straw. Los Angeles had had enough. We have to tame this killer river, this nightmare river. Those were the words you saw in the newspaper headlines at the time.
其中一件被冲走的东西是一只在电影里用过的大型合板鲸鱼。所以在那个短短的分钟里，洛杉矶河里出现了一只鲸鱼，尽管它是一只合板道具鲸，但这完美地概括了洛杉矶的特质。这场第三次洪水还让该年度最大的城市盛事陷入了停顿。那是1938年3月。3月通常会发生什么？奥斯卡金像奖。他们根本去不了奥斯卡颁奖典礼。这下我们真遇到危机了。因为电影明星们都被困住了，奥斯卡颁奖典礼不得不推迟了三天。那是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草。洛杉矶人受够了。我们必须驯服这条杀人河、这条噩梦般的河。这就是当时报纸头条上的词句。
Los Angeles residents were tired of living under the constant threat of flood. City leaders also hated the fact that the expanse of the river's floodplain took precious real estate off the market. So the city decided to take its most drastic step yet. It would carve out a 51-mile set pathway and seal the river into place with concrete. The river's sole purpose would be to funnel stormwater out to sea as quickly and efficiently as possible. Taking this enormous watershed and packing it into a narrow concrete channel was an incredibly
洛杉矶居民厌倦了生活在洪水不断的威胁之下。城市领导人也极其厌恶河漫滩占据了宝贵的房地产市场空间这一事实。于是，城市决定采取迄今为止最激进的举措。它将开辟一条长达51英里的固定通道，并用混凝土将河道固定死。这条河唯一的使命就是尽可能快、尽可能高效地将暴雨径流排入大海。把这个巨大的流域压缩进一条狭窄的混凝土水道，是一个极其
ambitious plan. But the United States at the time was in the depths of the Great Depression, and when the Army Corps of Engineers was tasked with this channelization project, it put 17,000 people to work. And so you had a massive government works project that was put underway where lawyers and dentists were out there working on paving the Los Angeles River. Over the next 21 years, the Army Corps of Engineers moved 20 million cubic yards of earth, poured 2 million cubic yards of concrete,
宏大的计划。但当时的美国正处于大萧条的谷底，当陆军工兵部队承担起这项河道渠化工程时，它为1.7万人提供了工作岗位。于是，一项庞大的政府公共工程轰轰烈烈地展开了，律师和牙医们都跑去铺设洛杉矶河。在接下来的21年里，陆军工兵部队搬运了2000万立方码的泥土，浇筑了200万立方码的混凝土，
and placed nearly 150,000 pounds of reinforced steel. It remains the largest public works project west of the Mississippi. This is Jenny Price, a writer and public artist. The river's trees were scraped away, its green spaces ripped out, its shorelines removed, its curves straightened. By 1960, the river had been completely transformed and then barricaded behind chain link fencing. They not only channelized the river and cemented the
并安置了近15万磅的钢筋。这依然是密西西比河以西最大的公共工程。这位是珍妮·普莱斯（Jenny Price），一位作家兼公共艺术家。河里的树木被铲除，绿地被撕裂，河岸被拆除，弯曲的河道被拉直。到1960年，这条河已经发生了彻底的蜕变，随后被铁丝网栅栏重重围住。他们不仅将河流渠道化、将河流水泥化、
river and paved the river, but they buried it, right? They dug the channel and put the river into it. So it's deep. You're in this kind of cavernous space. Trapping the river into a secure path meant that real estate developers could build properties like never before. A lot of the LA River basin was kind of wetlands that would flood seasonally. South LA was wet, West LA was wet, the valley was very, very wet. But thanks to the concrete channel, all of those different corners of the city were now dry. If you look at when those suburbs in West LA
将河流铺上混凝土，他们还将它埋葬了，对吧？他们挖出河道，把河放了进去。所以它是深陷其中的。你身处这种洞穴般的空间里。将河流禁锢在一条安全的路径中，意味着房地产开发商可以前所未有地开发物业。洛杉矶河盆地的很大一部分原本是季节性泛滥的湿地。南洛杉矶曾是湿地，西洛杉矶曾是湿地，山谷也曾经非常非常湿润。但多亏了混凝土河道，城市的所有这些不同角落现在都变干了。如果你看看西洛杉矶的那些郊区
and the valley in the South LA really mushroomed, it's right after that they concrete the LA River. The channelization of the river was an extreme, even violent approach to flood control. But in a way, the concrete did what city leaders at the time wanted it to do. The county, so far, has not experienced a flood as devastating as the one in 1938. And with the river fastened into place, Los Angeles was also able to urbanize at a breakneck speed. Now, nearly one million people live within a mile of the river.
以及山谷和南洛杉矶真正呈蘑菇云般爆发式增长的时期，就会发现那正是在他们给洛杉矶河铺上混凝土之后。河道的渠化是一种极端甚至暴力的防洪手段。但在某种程度上，混凝土确实达到了当时城市领导人预期的效果。迄今为止，该县再没有经历过像1938年那样毁灭性的洪水。随着河流被固定，洛杉矶也得以以惊人的速度实现城市化。如今，近百万人住在离河一英里的范围内。
But when Los Angeles traded its natural river for real estate, it got a lot more than it bargained for. Because in the process, we've created a slew of other environmental and social problems. You've taken a river and you've shut it off from its river basin. So water can flow into but not out of the river. So the river no longer replenishes the soil with nutrients, the aquifers with water, and the beaches with sand. At the same time, you have designed the infrastructure to get as much water as possible into the
但当洛杉矶用自然河流换取房地产时，它付出的代价远超预期。因为在这个过程中，我们制造了一系列其他环境和社会问题。你把一条河从它的流域切断了。所以水只能流入河中，却无法流出。因此，河水不再向土壤补充养分，不再向含水层补充水源，也不再向海滩补充沙子。与此同时，你设计了这样一套基础设施：尽可能多地把水排入
river as you can to drain all of the storm water into the storm sewers, into the tributaries, into the river, now to the Pacific Ocean. So how does LA manage its water? Takes all the water that gets for free from the sky, which we call rain, right? And designed its infrastructure to move all of that water as fast as possible out into the Pacific Ocean. And then it spends like a billion dollars a year to import from watersheds all across the West. It's significant ecological cost to all those watersheds. It's insane. It makes
河里，将所有的暴雨径流排入雨水下水道、排入支流、排入河流，最终排入太平洋。那么洛杉矶是如何管理其水资源的呢？它收集天空中免费得到的所有水——我们称之为雨水，对吧？——并设计了一套基础设施，以最快的速度将所有这些水排入太平洋。然后它每年花费大约十亿美元，从整个西部的各个流域引水。这对所有这些流域都造成了巨大的生态代价。这太疯狂了。这完全
absolutely no sense. By the time the project was completed in 1960, most people thought of the LA River as a flood control channel. Generations of Angelenos grew up without ever realizing that we once had a powerful river and that it made this city possible. My kids are teenagers now. And you know, you're driving around downtown LA and you see the sign Los Angeles River.
说不通。到1960年该工程竣工时，大多数人都把洛杉矶河看作是一个防空洪/防洪通道。一代又一代的洛杉矶人成长过程中，甚至从未意识到我们曾经拥有一条气势磅礴的河流，正是它造就了这座城市。我的孩子现在都是青少年了。你知道的，当你开车绕着洛杉矶市中心转时，你会看到“洛杉矶河”的标志。
This is Christina Martina, secretary for the Gabrieleno Band of Mission Indians, Keetch Nation. And last time we were downtown, I'm like, mom, there's a river? I said, well, when we get to it, look over the edge and tell me what you see. And they're like, there's nothing there.
这位是克里斯蒂娜·马蒂娜（Christina Martina），加布里埃利诺部落印第安人基奇族的秘书。她说：“我们上次去市中心时，我说：‘妈妈，这儿有条河？’我说：‘等我们到了那儿，朝边缘往下看，告诉我你看到了什么。’他们说：‘下面什么都没有。’”
It's just concrete, I said. Yep. I said, look at how wide that concrete ditch is, right? Imagine all that concrete gone, and that was full of water at one point. So, you know, my kids will never know what the LA River looked like. You can only imagine. What was your relationship to the river growing up? Did you have one? None. None. That's all I know as well. It's just the concrete jungle of it all.
“‘只有混凝土。’我说：‘没错。’我说：‘看看那条混凝土水沟有多宽，对吧？想象一下所有的混凝土都消失了，曾经这里面全是水。’所以，你知道的，我的孩子永远不会知道洛杉矶河曾经是什么样子。你只能去想象。”你小时候跟这条河有什么关系吗？你有过吗？完全没有。完全没有。这也是我所知道的全部。只剩下它那水泥森林般的模样了。
Yep. After the LA River was paved, it remained mostly ignored for decades. Even though it ran straight through the heart of Los Angeles County, people forgot it was there. For all intents and purposes, the river was just another piece of infrastructure. There was a proposal by a state assemblyman to use the river as a freeway during the dry season. There was a proposal to paint the channel blue. It was difficult to see the river as anything other than a punchline.
没错。洛杉矶河被水泥硬化之后，在长达几十年的时间里基本上被无视了。尽管它径直穿过了洛杉矶县的心脏地带，人们却把它忘得一干二净。无论从什么角度来看，这条河都只是又一件基础设施而已。曾有一位州议员提议在旱季将这条河当作高速公路使用。曾有人提议把河道漆成蓝色。人们很难把这条河看作是一个笑话之外的任何东西。
The word river seemed like a weird euphemism for this concrete ditch that people actively avoided. But in the 1980s, 20 plus years after the LA River was paved, something slowly began to change. Some people in Los Angeles started looking at the river a little differently. They began to question whether the river had to be like this. The first and loudest of these people was an artist named Louis McAdams.
“河流”这个词听起来像是对这条人们唯恐避之不及的混凝土水沟的一个奇怪委婉说法。但在20世纪80年代，即洛杉矶河被水泥硬化20多年后，情况开始悄然发生变化。洛杉矶的一些人开始用一种略微不同的眼光看待这条河。他们开始质疑这条河是否必须保持这副模样。这些人中最先发声、声音也最大的是一位名叫路易斯·麦克亚当斯（Louis McAdams）的艺术家。
He was a poet and a performance artist in a pork pie hat. And his first realizations about the LA River came when he and his friends had been like smoking a little something something and went down to the river which was fenced off and got some wire cutters and went on in. From that moment on, McAdams was determined to be an advocate for the LA River. In 1986, he founded an organization called Friends of the Los Angeles River,
他是一位头戴猪肉派帽的诗人和行为艺术家。他对洛杉矶河最初的顿悟发生在他和朋友们抽了点小叶子、走到被铁丝网围起来的河边、拿来剪线钳剪开网子走进去的时候。从那一刻起，麦克亚当斯下定决心要成为洛杉矶河的拥护者。1986年，他创立了一个名为“洛杉矶河之友”的组织，
which was made up of other artists and architects. They made it their mission to get Angelenos and policymakers to start thinking and caring about their river again. The way that we move water through the Los Angeles region is enormously insane and enormously screwed up, but as screwed up as it is, the LA River is still the central artery of the major watershed and has never ceased to be that. Eventually the LA River went from being a niche artistic project to a mainstream one. Other groups and individuals started asking questions like, what if we restored some of
成员由其他艺术家和建筑师组成。他们的使命就是让洛杉矶人和政策制定者重新开始思考和关爱他们的河流。我们在洛杉矶地区输送水资源的方式极其疯狂，也搞得一团糟，但尽管如此糟糕，洛杉矶河依然是主要流域的核心动脉，而且从未停止过发挥这种作用。最终，洛杉矶河从一个生态位艺术项目演变成了主流项目。其他团体和个人开始提出诸如以下的问题：如果我们恢复混凝土河岸沿线的一些
the natural habitat along its concrete banks? What if the river could be part of a solution to our constant drought? What if the river became a place that people wanted to visit rather than avoid? What if we built some damn parks? McAdams and other river advocates believed that before anything physical could happen, Angelenos had to change the way they were thinking and speaking about the LA River. If we wanted people to stop treating the river like a flood control channel, we had to stop calling it a flood control channel. There's a famous story where Lewis was at some meeting and whenever someone from the
自然栖息地会怎样？如果这条河能成为解决我们持续干旱问题的一部分方案会怎样？如果这条河能成为一个人们想要参观而不是逃离的地方会怎样？如果我们建几个该死的公园会怎样？麦克亚当斯和其他河流倡导者认为，在发生任何实际改变之前，洛杉矶人必须改变他们思考和谈论洛杉矶河的方式。如果我们希望人们停止像对待防洪渠那样对待这条河，我们就必须停止称其为防洪渠。有个著名的故事说，路易斯在某次会议上，每当县里或工程兵团的人说“呃，防洪渠”时，他就说“河”。就像是：防洪渠，河；防洪渠，河。
county or the chorus said, uh, flood control chain, he said river. It was like flood control channel, river, flood control channel, river. Yeah. It's the power of, of words, right? Power of, um, owning words and owning the river as a river. This is Candace Dickens Russell, president and CEO of Friends of the Los Angeles River. It's the nature versus built. And I think that's the thing that changes in people's minds when they talk about it as a river. It's something that deserves to be here as
是的。这就是语言的力量，对吧？掌控语言、将河流视为河流本身的力量。这位是坎迪斯·迪肯斯·罗素（Candace Dickens Russell），“洛杉矶河之友”的总裁兼首席执行官。这是自然与人工的对比。我认为这就是当人们称其为“河”时，在人们心中发生转变的东西。它是一个理应存在于此的事物，
opposed to a flood control channel. Oh, they just built that so that we could solve some problems. After years and years of grassroots activism, by the early 2000s, the river, to be honest, still looked like a concrete monstrosity, but things were actually getting better. A few pocket parks had sprung up along the river, and it helped that years earlier a water reclamation plant opened upstream, which meant that the river actually always had at least some water in it. It was by no means the Danube. You still probably couldn't pay people to get into the water, but it was an improvement.
而不是一条防洪渠。哦，他们建那个只是为了解决一些问题。经过多年坚持不懈的基层行动，到2000年代初，老实说，这条河看起来依然像个混凝土庞然大物，但情况确实在好转。河畔涌现出了几个口袋公园，而且几年前上游开设了一座水质净化厂，这意味着这条河实际上总算始终保有一点水流了。它远远比不上多瑙河。你可能仍然花钱也请不到人下水游泳，但这确实是一种改善。
But in 2006, right in the middle of the Los Angeles River's comeback, a Supreme Court decision pulled the emergency break on all of that positive momentum. It imperiled the wetlands in the LA River basin. It was a case called Ropano's versus the United States, and it challenged protections granted by the Clean Water Act. The Clean Water Act states that it's illegal to discharge any pollutant into,
但在2006年，正当洛杉矶河迎来复兴之际，最高法院的一项裁决给所有这些积极的势头踩下了紧急刹车。它危及了洛杉矶河盆地的湿地。这是一起名为“罗帕诺诉美国案”（Rapanos v. United States）的诉讼，它挑战了《清洁水法》（Clean Water Act）所赋予的保护措施。《清洁水法》规定，向以下水体排放任何污染物是非法的：
quote, navigable waters. What this case in particular argued was that wetlands and ephemeral rivers like the L.A. River didn't count as, quote, navigable waters because they dried out for a lot of the year. It basically came down to, can you float a boat on it? Yes or no. If not, you can dump pollution into it. The upstream folks, conservative upstream folks,
引述，“通航水域”。这起案件具体争论的焦点在于，湿地和像洛杉矶河这样的季节性河流不属于引述的“通航水域”，因为它们在一年中的大部分时间里都是干涸的。这基本上归结为一个问题：你能在上面开船吗？行还是不行？如果不行，你就可以往里面倾倒污染。上游的人们，保守的上游人们，
finally got what they'd been wanting for a long time, right? Which is that they wanted to declassify most wetlands as being protected under the Clean Water Act. Sure enough, in 2008, the Army Corps of Engineers, who had jurisdiction over a lot of the river, ruled that of the 51 miles of river, less than four were navigable and therefore worthy of protection. This decision was essentially granting permission to polluters and developers to treat the river like crap again. Taking away its clean water protections was basically accepting that the LA River
终于得到了他们长期以来一直想要的东西，对吧？那就是他们希望将大多数湿地取消归类为受《清洁水法》保护的对象。果不其然，2008年，对这条河的大部分河段拥有管辖权的陆军工兵部队裁定，在全长51英里的河流中，具备通航条件的不到4英里，因此不值得保护。这项裁决基本上是给污染者和开发商发放了许可，让他们可以再次把这条河当成垃圾场对待。剥夺其清洁水保护措施，基本上就等于默认了洛杉矶河
would never be more than a flood control channel, setting back decades of forward thinking momentum achieved by environmentalists. If this decision had happened 30 years earlier, perhaps nobody in Los Angeles would have put up a fight. But after decades of activism, the LA River finally had some advocates and one unexpected ally. Hi, my name is Heather Wiley. I worked for the Army Corps of Engineers. I left as a whistleblower.
永远不会只是一条防洪渠，这也让环保主义者几十年来取得的前瞻性势头倒退了回去。如果这项决定是在30年前作出的，或许洛杉矶不会有人站出来抗争。但在几十年的积极行动后，洛杉矶河终于有了一些支持者，以及一个意想不到的盟友。嗨，我叫海瑟·威利（Heather Wiley）。我曾为陆军工兵部队工作。我离职时是一名内部举报人。
At the time, Heather Wiley, who declined an interview for this story, was working as a biologist within the Army Corps of Engineers. My agency, the Army Corps of Engineers, decided to take it upon themselves and... When she learned that her organization was about to strip the LA River
当时，拒绝接受本故事采访的海瑟·威利正在陆军工兵部队担任生物学家。我的机构——陆军工兵部队决定自行其是，然后……当她得知自己的组织准备剥夺洛杉矶河
of its clean water protections, she got to work. Wiley leaked the information to a number of top environmental lawyers, as well as the House Oversight Committee. At the same time, she was also furiously researching to find any proof that the river actually was traditional navigable. Which led her to a YouTube video called George's LA River Commute.
的清洁水保护时，她行动了起来。威利将这一信息泄露给了多位顶级环境律师以及众议院监督委员会。与此同时，她还在疯狂地查阅资料，寻找任何能够证明这条河实际上属于传统通航水域的证据。这引领她找到了一个名为《乔治的洛杉矶河通勤》（George's LA River Commute）的YouTube视频。
It's a short comedy video that was posted on YouTube. You see a goateed guy in a suit, trapped in his car in standstill LA traffic. Out of frustration, he gets out of his car, hops in a kayak, and wraps down the LA River, all set to the music of Green River by CCR. We were coming at it from a, well, isn't this goofy, isn't this funny? Here's LA traffic, of course everybody relates to that, and here's this guy who manages to get off the freeway and get in the boat. And that's just seemed like a quintessential LA situation.
这是一个发布在YouTube上的短喜剧视频。你可以看到一个留着山羊胡、穿着西装的男子，被困在他那堵在洛杉矶停滞不前的车流中的汽车里。出于沮丧，他下了车，跳进皮划艇，顺着洛杉矶河漂流而下，背景音乐播放着CCR乐队的《绿河》（Green River）。我们当时以一种“这不是很滑稽、不是很搞笑吗”的心态来看待它。这里是洛杉矶的交通拥堵，当然每个人都能感同身受，而这里有这么一个家伙，设法下了高速公路，坐进了船里。这似乎是一种非常典型的洛杉矶场景。
This is George Wolfe, the George of George's LA River commute. He and a friend had posted the video for fun thinking that just a handful of people would see it. But when Heather Wiley clicked on that YouTube link, she realized that this could be the way to prove the LA River was in fact navigable. So she called up George immediately. And it took Heather sort of hashing some of this stuff out in a very kind of manic way over the phone. She's like, I saw the video on the river and you have to get out there. What are you doing? You got to get the news. You have to get this covered. And we need to see people in boats on the river.
这位是乔治·沃尔夫（George Wolfe），也就是《乔治的洛杉矶河通勤》里的那个乔治。他和一位朋友出于好玩发布了这个视频，心想大概只有少数人会看到。但当海瑟·威利点击那个YouTube链接时，她意识到这可能是证明洛杉矶河确实具有通航性的方法。于是她立刻给乔治打了电话。海瑟在电话里以一种非常狂热的方式和乔治梳理了这些事情。她说：“我在河上看到了那个视频，你必须去那里。你在干什么？你得找新闻。你得让这事受到报道。我们需要看到人们在河上的船里。”
And I'm like, who are you again? After determining that she was not in fact an Army Corps spy, George signed on to help. He would play one part in Wiley's plan to save the river's clean water protections. In her mind she was like, oh, here are these boaters. That'll be one part of the whole strategy. And she was already reaching out to her congressman, and he's going to approach it from this whole other very large political angle. And how that works with the Supreme Court, I don't know. You're a guy in a kayak.
而我的反应是：“你到底是谁啊？”在确认她并不是陆军工兵部队的间谍后，乔治同意提供帮助。他将在威利拯救河流清洁水保护的计划中扮演一个角色。在她心目中，她是这么想的：“哦，这里有这些划船的人。这将成为整个战略的一部分。”她当时已经联系了她的国会议员，而国会议员将从另一个非常宏大的政治角度来处理此事。至于这招对最高法院管不管用，我不知道。你只是个坐在皮划艇里的家伙。
I'm a guy in a boat, you know, and we tend to be simpler folks. George assembled a group of a couple dozen kayakers, including Wiley, for a three-day kayaking trip down all 51 miles of the river. They scheduled the trip for the dead of summer when the water runs at its lowest, just to prove that even under the harshest conditions, it was possible. And in July of 2008, the fleet launched at the river's headwaters at Kenoga Park High School
我只是个坐在船里的人，你知道的，我们往往是比较简单的人。乔治召集了包括威利在内的两十几名皮划艇爱好者，进行了一次为期三天的皮划艇之旅，顺流而下完成了全部51英里的河程。他们把行程安排在盛夏水流最低的时候，就是为了证明即使在最恶劣的条件下，这也是可行的。2008年7月，这支船队在位于坎加帕克高中（Kenoga Park High School）的河流源头启航，
amongst the concrete, chain-link fences, and do-not-enter signs. Inevitably helicopters show up, you know, the helicopters swoop around and then before long a couple of policemen on foot show up. Not long into the trip, the police stopped the caravan to see if they had permits to be on the river. They didn't have one to kayak the river, but as it turns out, George's wife, Taya, was filming a documentary about the whole river trip, and they were actually
在一片混凝土、铁丝网栅栏和“禁止进入”的标志中出发。直升机不可避免地出现了，你懂的，直升机盘旋着，不久之后，两名步行巡逻的警察也出现了。行程刚开始没多久，警察就拦下了这支队伍，检查他们是否有在河上划船的许可证。他们并没有划船的许可证碰巧的是，乔治的妻子塔娅（Taya）正在拍摄一部关于整场河流之旅的纪录片，而他们实际上
able to present a film permit instead. Because it's LA, it's easier to get a film permit to go on the LA River than it is to get any other kind of permit to access the river. So they looked it over and they were like, well, they have a film permit. I don't know. Who are we to stop them? And so they carried on through the San Fernando Valley, around the movie studios, through downtown LA, avoiding discarded refrigerators and shopping carts. Along the way, they could see the soft bottom portions of the river where the concrete refused to take, and trees and plants managed to find a way up despite the channelization. And yet you see the hope because you see the trees and the brush all pop up through it.
可以用电影拍摄许可证来应付。因为这里是洛杉矶，在洛杉矶河上拍电影比拿到任何其他进入河流的许可证都要容易。所以他们检查了一下，然后说：“嗯，他们有电影许可证。我不知道。我们凭什么阻止他们？”于是他们继续前行，穿过圣费尔南多谷，绕过电影制片厂，穿过洛杉矶市中心，避开被丢弃的冰箱和购物车。一路上，他们看到了河里拒绝被混凝土覆盖的天然河床部分，在水泥化之下，树木和植物依然顽强地找到了生长出来的方式。然而你看到了希望，因为你看到树木和灌木丛从中破土而出。
You see majestic birds like the great white herons and the egrets and kingfishers and you know those red-legged stilt birds. And you see you know owls and hawks and an amazing panorama of life going on. So it's, and that's the thing that makes the LA River the LA River is the weird juxtaposition of stuff. They watched as the walls of the river itself morphed as they headed south, from narrow towering concrete walls
你会看到像大白鹭、白鹭、翠鸟这样的雄伟鸟类，还有那些红腿高翅长脚鹬。你还会看到猫头鹰、老鹰，以及一幅生生不息的惊艳全景画卷。所以，正是这一点——让洛杉矶河成为洛杉矶河的，正是这种奇特的事物并存。随着他们向南行进，河岸的墙壁也在不断变化，从狭窄高耸的混凝土墙
to a wide open trapezoidal channel, to that final open stretch out to Queensway Bay and Long Beach. We could see the Queen Mary in the distance, which was kind of ironic. Here we were in these little teeny tiny boats and there was this majestic ocean liner awaiting us at the very end. It seemed appropriate as an ending point. After a round of celebratory pizzas in the parking lot, the group headed home.
变成宽阔开阔的梯形河道，再到通往女王韦湾（Queensway Bay）和长滩（Long Beach）的最后开阔河段。我们能在远处看到玛丽女王号（Queen Mary），这多少有点讽刺。我们坐着这些微型小船，而一艘雄伟的远洋客轮正静静地在终点等待着我们。作为终点，这似乎再合适不过了。在停车场享用了一轮庆祝披萨后，大家便启程回家了。
George and his team collected data and measurements during the trip and wrote up their experience into a big report. And we sent it off to the EPA and then didn't hear anything. It took two years, but in 2010, the EPA stepped in and overruled the Army Corps of Engineers, declaring that all 51 miles of the LA River were navigable and therefore would keep all of its Clean Water Act protections. We were all just kind of like, you know, that last scene in the whiz, they're just singing brand new day and dancing in the streets. It felt like that. We were just like, whoa, the LA River is navigable.
乔治和他的团队在旅行期间收集了数据和测量结果，并将他们的经历写成了一份厚厚的报告。我们把它寄给了环保署（EPA），然后就石沉大海、杳无音信了。历时两年，但在2010年，环保署介入并推翻了陆军工兵部队的决定，宣布洛杉矶河全长51英里的河段均具备通航性，因此将保留其《清洁水法》的所有保护措施。我们当时的感觉就像……你知道的，就像电影《新绿野仙踪》（The Wiz）里的最后一个场景，他们只是在唱着崭新的一天，在街头舞蹈。感觉就像那样。我们当时的想法就是：“哇，洛杉矶河竟然可以通航！”
This is Candace Dickens Russell again, CEO of Friends of the LA River. It was a buzz. It kind of rippled through the office and everybody was just like, oh my gosh, this thing just happened. It was a big deal. It was a big deal because it meant that there were gonna be some formal
这位又是坎迪斯·迪肯斯·罗素，洛杉矶河之友的首席执行官。那真是一阵轰动。消息在办公室里流传开来，每个人都在说：“哦，天哪，这事居然真的发生了。”这可是件大事。这之所以是件大事，是因为这意味着将会有一些正式的、
and very real protections for the river that were coming in. The kayaking stunt helped to restore the river's environmental protections and renewed a lot of interest in it. But river advocates say that there is still a lot to be done when it comes to revitalization. The community surrounding the river has been surveyed so many times. They've been asked what they want so many times and so little of that has come to fruition.
非常切实的河流保护措施即将出台。这次皮划艇特技活动帮助恢复了河流的环境保护措施，并重新激起了人们对它的极大兴趣。但河流倡导者表示，在复兴工作方面，依然有大量工作要做。围绕这条河的社区已经被调查过无数次了。他们被问过无数次自己想要什么，但其中真正付诸实现的却寥寥无几。
We have work to do. We have serious work to do. The river itself passes through 17 different cities, as well as county and federal jurisdiction. It also impacts a number of different communities. So there are a lot of conflicting ideas for how to make the river a better place for Angelenos, or how to do it in a way that respects native ecology, or how to do it in a way that avoids green gentrification, or how to do it in a way that avoids green gentrification, or how to do it equitably.
我们还有工作要做。我们有大量正经工作要做。这条河本身流经17个不同的城市，还涉及县级和联邦管辖区。它还影响着许多不同的社区。因此，关于如何让这条河对洛杉矶人来说变得更好、如何以尊重本土生态的方式去做、如何避免绿色生态绅士化，或者如何以公平的方式去做，存在着许多相互冲突的想法。
It's slow work. But although there has been disagreement on what revitalization should look like or how we'll get there, there is one thing that all of these agencies and organizations and advocacy groups and individuals and kayakers can agree on. The LA River is a river. I'm gonna hand out some paddles to you. Oh my gosh. All right. Listener, we are scrambling. After George Wolfe helped to reestablish the river's navigability status, he founded LA River Expeditions, which leads kayak tours at certain spots of the LA River. Since then, the group has gotten around 15 to 20,000 people
这是一项缓慢的工作。但尽管在复兴应该是什么样子或我们该如何达成目标方面存在分歧，所有这些机构、组织、倡导团体、个人和皮划艇运动员有一点是达成共识的。洛杉矶河就是一条河。我要给你们每人发几支桨。哦，天哪。好吧。听众朋友们，我们要出发了。在乔治·沃尔夫帮助恢复了这条河的通航地位后，他创立了“洛杉矶河远征队”（LA River Expeditions），在洛杉矶河的某些特定河段带队进行皮划艇旅游。从那以后，该组织已经让大约1.5万到2万人
into boats and out on the water. Last summer, Vivian and I were two of them, which for very indoor people was a huge gamble. Can you say something for me? One, two, one, two. One, two, one, two. I'm very afraid. Just kidding.
坐上船来到了水面上。去年夏天，薇薇安和我就是其中两人，对于极少出门的人来说，这可是一次巨大的冒险。你能帮我试下音吗？一二，一二。一二，一二。我好害怕。开玩笑的啦。
We met up at the Sepulveda Basin, which is one of the few natural sections of the river that was never concreted. To be quite honest, the launch site was not much to look at. It was a wide open scraggly overflow zone. A big concrete overpass was blocking part of the river view and parked along the banks were some shopping carts filled with scrap.
我们在塞普尔韦达盆地会合，这里是洛杉矶河为数不多从未被水泥化的自然河段之一。老实说，下水点其实没什么好看的。那是一个开阔、杂草丛生的泄洪区。一座巨大的混凝土立交桥挡住了部分河景，岸边停着一些装满废品的购物车。
I'm on the river. I'm wearing a helmet. I'm wearing a helmet. I'm observing. I see a pipe, a rusty pipe ahead. But once we rounded the bend, under the belly of that big concrete overpass, you could see it. It's still a river full of life.
我在河上了。我戴着头盔。我戴着头盔。我在观察。我看到前方有一根管道，一根生锈的管道。但一旦我们绕过河湾，在那个巨大的混凝土立交桥桥洞底下，你就能看到了。这依然是一条充满生机的河流。
Whoa, Canadian geese flying above. And although city leaders tried to bury it, it's still here. Ooh, there's fish here. There's a bunch of little fish here. Bunch of little baby guys. You can get a small sense of what the LA River once was. And even though it represents so much
哇，加拿大雁在头顶飞过。尽管城市领导层试图掩埋它，但它依然存在。哦，这里有鱼。这里有一群小鱼。一群小鱼苗。你可以稍微体会一下洛杉矶河曾经的模样。尽管它代表了许多
of what we did wrong in Los Angeles, it is also a reminder that we could still get it right. Beautiful. Flying egret. Yeah, gorgeous. Gorgeous, gorgeous, gorgeous. After the break, Gillian comes back to talk more about the LA River. Stay with us.
我们在洛杉矶做错了的事情，它也提醒着我们，我们仍然可以把它做好。太美了。飞翔的白鹭。是的，太美了。太美了，太美了，太美了。广告之后，吉莉安将回来继续聊聊洛杉矶河。请继续收听。
So I am back with producer and friend of the show Gillian Jacobs. Hello, friend. Hi, friend. How are you? I'm good. How are you doing? I'm doing great. Yeah, so we like to use these CODES to chat about the things that we came across while reporting our stories, but for whatever reason, they don't make it into the episode.
欢迎回来，我是制作人兼节目好友吉莉安·雅各布斯。你好，朋友。嗨，朋友。你好吗？我很好。你怎么样？我很好。对，所以我们喜欢用这些代号来闲聊我们在报道故事时遇到的一些事情，但出于某种原因，这些内容没能进入正片。
And today, we actually wanted to talk about two things. The first being a story about what the LA River could have been. Yes. So in our reporting, we discovered that in the 1930s, as we all know, Los Angeles city leaders turned to concrete as the solution to the city's flooding issues. But you and I learned that it didn't have to be this way. There was actually an alternative idea for flood control being thrown around a few years earlier
而今天，我们其实想聊两件事。第一件事是关于洛杉矶河本该是什么样子的故事。是的。所以在我们的报道中，我们发现，在20世纪30年代，正如我们所知，洛杉矶市的领导层转向用混凝土来解决城市的洪涝问题。但你和我了解到，事情本不必如此。其实在几年前，就有一个关于防洪的替代方案在流传
that would have created a very different Los Angeles. In the late 20s, early 30s, the city, and I think the Chamber of Commerce commissioned a study, and they said, look at Los Angeles. We're on this point of incredible growth. What should the city look like? That's Pat Morrison, again, author of Rio LA. So she says that in the late 1920s, as Los Angeles was experiencing this super rapid
这将创造一个截然不同的洛杉矶。在20世纪20年代末、30年代初，市政府，我想还有商会委托了一项研究，他们说，看看洛杉矶。我们正处于令人难以置信的增长点上。这座城市应该是什么样子的？那是帕特·莫里森，她是《里约热内卢洛杉矶》一书的作者。所以她说，在20世纪20年代末，随着洛杉矶经历这种超级快速的
growth, the LA Chamber of Commerce actually had all of these concerns about all of the things that came with population growth, stuff like pollution and traffic and disappearing public park space. And there were already by this point conversations about constraining the LA River and some in the chamber worried that this approach would just make these other issues way worse. Which was absolutely correct. They were dead on. And also listen to the 99 PI episode about America's lost public transit.
增长，洛杉矶商会其实对人口增长带来的所有问题都感到担忧，比如污染、交通以及消失的公共公园空间。而且到这个时候，已经有了关于约束洛杉矶河的讨论，商会中的一些人担心这种做法只会让这些其他问题变得更加严重。这绝对是正确的。他们完全切中要害。也请去听听99号无形关于美国消失的公共交通的那集。
If you want to hear more about why we don't have better public transportation in Los Angeles. Yes, shout out to our own show. So okay I'm taking you back. So at the time the chamber formed a subcommittee of about a hundred different high-profile Angelenos. One member was the director Cecil B. DeMille. Another was the actress Mary Pickford. Very important person in the early history of Hollywood. Google her if you've never heard of her. Please do. And this committee commissioned a proposal for the urban redesign of Los Angeles that would tackle all of these other issues as well as the flooding problem. And when I finally saw it, I started to cry because it was the city that we never got
如果你想了解更多关于为什么洛杉矶没有更好的公共交通的原因。是的，为我们自己的节目打个call。所以，好吧，我带你们回到过去。当时商会成立了一个由大约一百位各界知名洛杉矶人组成的小组委员会。其中一位成员是导演塞西尔·B·德米尔。另一位是女演员玛丽·皮克福德。好莱坞早期历史中的重要人物。如果你没听说过她，去谷歌一下。请一定要去。这个委员会委托了一份关于洛杉矶城市重新规划的提案，旨在解决所有这些其他问题以及防洪问题。当我最终看到它时，我开始哭泣，因为它就是我们从未得到但本该得到的城市
that we should have gotten. It was called the Emerald Necklace. So the Emerald Necklace proposal was co-created by the sons of Frederick Law Olmsted, who was actually the landscape architect that designed Central Park. And Olmsted Senior designed something very similar in Boston decades earlier.
我们本该拥有的城市。它被称为“翡翠项链”。所以“翡翠项链”提案是由弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德的儿子们共同创建的，他其实是设计了中央公园的景观设计师。奥姆斯特德高级在此几十年前就在波士顿设计了非常相似的东西。
And like that plan, the Los Angeles Emerald Necklace imagined a series of interconnected parks and greenways along the coast and all throughout the city. And it would have created a more natural river path and also absorbed flood overflow. And if you look at it, keeping that intact, even marginally intact as greents, as overflow zones, would have made this a paradise.
就像那个计划一样，洛杉矶的“翡翠项链”设想了一系列沿海以及遍布全市的互联公园和绿道。它将创造一条更自然的河道，并吸收防洪溢流。如果你看一下它，保持其完整，哪怕作为绿地、泄洪区保持轻微的完整，都会让这里成为人间天堂。
Much as we love it now, we know it is an imperfect paradise. I don't know about paradise, but it would have been awesome. And the Olmstead Plan wouldn't have just provided protection from floodwater. It would have connected the entire city by green space. And rather than funneling out precious rainwater to the ocean, a lot of it would be able to absorb back into the water table through these parks. Right. Yeah, that's so sad to think about.
正如我们现在所爱它的一样，我们知道这是一个不完美的天堂。我不知道这算不算天堂，但它肯定棒极了。而且奥姆斯特德计划不仅能提供防洪保护。它将通过绿地连接整个城市。而且许多珍贵的雨水不会被排入海洋，而是能够通过这些公园重新渗入地下水层。对。是的，想到这些真是太令人难过了。
It would have solved so many issues. So what ended up happening with the Olmstead Plan? Well, unsurprising, the proposal was shot down immediately. It was actually killed by the Chamber of Commerce itself, which was the entity that commissioned the plan. And almost no one even knew it existed for decades. It took too much stuff off the market. And it was the Depression.
它本可以解决那么多问题。那么奥姆斯特德计划最后怎么样了？好吧，毫不意外，这个提案一出来就被否决了。它实际上是被委托该计划的机构——商会本身给扼杀的。而且几十年来，几乎没有人知道它的存在。它把太多的土地从市场上拿走了。而且当时正值大萧条。
We couldn't afford it. And so now we have to live with the consequences 100 years on. It is striking how the Olmstead plan was, you know, the exact opposite approach to flood management that we ended up with. And it would have created like a fundamentally different Los Angeles. You know, you and I both live here and it's, it's not that Angelino's don't value park space, but it does feel like built into Los Angeles is the feeling that, you know, this kind of public space is not a priority for the
我们负担不起。所以现在我们不得不在100年后承受这些后果。令人震惊的是，奥姆斯特德计划与我们最终得到的防洪管理方法完全相反。它本可以创造一个截然不同的洛杉矶。你知道，你我都住在这里，虽然并不是说洛杉矶人不重视公园空间，但确实感觉洛杉矶骨子里有一种观念，那就是这种公共空间不是
city itself. Yeah, and you have good reason for that feeling. So the trust for public land puts out a park score rating, you know, the hundred most populous cities in the country, and Los Angeles ranked 88 out of 100, which is... That's really bad. That's such a bummer. Yes, yes. I mean, you could feel it, but that is such a bummer. I know.
城市本身的首要任务。是的，你有充分的理由产生这种感觉。所以公园土地信托基金会发布了一个公园评分评级，评估了全国人口最多的前一百个城市，而洛杉矶在100个城市中排名第88位，这……这真的很糟。太让人沮丧了。是的，是的。我的意思是，你能感觉到，但这真的太让人沮丧了。我懂。
We know it's bad. I didn't know it was that bad. And I did want to say that the Olmsted plant has served as an inspiration for some of the proposals to revitalize the LA River. So one day we might see some elements of that design. I don't know. We'll see. I mean, don't make Pat Morrison cry. That's just what I want to say to LA power figures. Yes, protect Pat Morrison at all costs. At all costs. Please. Don't make her cry ever again.
我们知道这很糟糕。我没想到会这么糟。我确实想说，奥姆斯特德计划为一些旨在复兴洛杉矶河的提案提供了灵感。所以总有一天我们可能会看到该设计的某些元素。我不知道。我们走着瞧。我的意思是，别把帕特·莫里森弄哭了。这就是我想对洛杉矶当权者说的话。是的，不惜一切代价保护帕特·莫里森。不惜一切代价。求求了。再也别把她弄哭了。
Yeah. So maybe one day we'll see some reflection of the emerald necklace in Los Angeles if we could ever get her act together. And that's the good news. That's the good news portion of the quota. And originally it was going to be the only thing we were going to talk about, but something very recently happened in the news and it felt like it was important that we talked about it because it could possibly impact the future of the LA River.
是的。所以也许有一天，如果我们能把这个城市治理好，我们会在洛杉矶看到翡翠项链的一些影子。这就是好消息。这是额度中的好消息部分。原本它将是我们唯一要谈论的事情，但最近新闻中发生了一件事，我们觉得讨论它很重要，因为它可能会影响洛杉矶河的未来。
Yes. So a big part of the main episode was this key moment in 2008 when the LA River's clean water protections were put in jeopardy because of an interpretation of a Supreme Court decision. So Vivian, do you want to take away the recap? Sure, yes. So the Clean Water Act protects, quote,
是的。所以主剧集很大一部分是2008年的这个关键时刻，当时由于对最高法院裁决的解释，洛杉矶河的清洁水质保护措施受到了威胁。维维安，你想来做个回顾吗？当然，可以。所以《清洁水法》保护的是，引述一下
navigable bodies of water. That's the language of the law itself. And then in 2008, the Army Corps of Engineers declared the LA River non-navigable. But eventually, the EPA stepped in and overruled the Army Corps of Engineers and declared that the LA River was navigable again, which preserved its Clean Water Act protections. Yes, so the EPA was able to step in and preserve the LA River was navigable again, which preserved its Clean Water Act protections. Yes. So the EPA was able to step in and preserve the LA River's clean water protections because
可航行的水体。这就是法律本身的语言。然后在2008年，陆军工兵部队宣布洛杉矶河为不可航行。但最终，环保局介入并推翻了陆军工兵部队的决定，宣布洛杉矶河再次具有可航行性，从而保留了其《清洁水法》的保护。是的，所以环保局能够介入并保留洛杉矶河再次具有可航行性，从而保留了其《清洁水法》的保护。是的。所以环保局能够介入并保留洛杉矶河的清洁水质保护，因为
of this long-standing precedent called the Chevron Doctrine. The Chevron Doctrine basically meant that when a law is vague or ambiguous, federal courts need to defer to an agency like the EPA to interpret that law. So the reason why the L.A. River was able to keep its clean water protections was because the Clean Water Act had this ambiguous language, quote, navigable waters. So the EPA had the power to interpret the meaning of navigable. Right. Because there was some confusion about the language of the Clean Water Act, scientists and biologists and engineers that work within the EPA as an Because there was some confusion about the language of the Clean Water Act, scientists
这个长期存在的先例被称为“雪佛龙原则”。“雪佛龙原则”基本上意味着，当法律模糊不清或模棱两可时，联邦法院需要服从像环保局这样的机构来解释该法律。所以洛杉矶河能够保留其清洁水质保护的原因是，《清洁水法》有这样模糊的语言，即“可航行水域”。因此，环保局有权解释“可航行”的含义。对。由于对《清洁水法》的语言存在一些混淆，作为环保局内部的科学家、生物学家和工程师，由于对《清洁水法》的语言存在一些混淆，科学家
and biologists and engineers that work within the EPA, as an entity, they were allowed to make the decision of whether the LA River specifically was worth protecting rather than in court by some non-expert judge. Yes. But while we were reporting this story, the Supreme Court overturned the Chevron Doctrine. And so now it's not clear how long the EPA's protections will last. Which is super scary. Like that is really scary.
和生物学家以及作为实体在环保局工作的工程师，他们被允许做出决定，即洛杉矶河具体是否值得保护，而不是由某个非专家法官在法庭上决定。是的。但在我们报道这个故事时，最高法院推翻了“雪佛龙原则”。所以现在还不清楚环保局的保护能持续多久。这超级可怕。这真的超级可怕。
This is my version of a horror film. We don't know if this is going to have an impact on the LA River. And there is a possibility that someone else in the future will challenge the river's clean water protections and this ends up in court, but maybe not. I don't know. Yeah, right. And it's important to note that this ruling has other huge implications to outside of the alley river.
这是我的恐怖片版本。我们不知道这是否会对洛杉矶河产生影响。并且有可能未来会有其他人挑战该河的清洁水质保护，这最终闹上法庭，但也可能不会。我不知道。是的，没错。值得注意的是，这项裁决在洛杉矶河之外也有其他巨大的影响。
Protections for other ephemeral waterways like wetlands and creeks can be challenged. It also means that, you know, all sorts of federal regulations could end up in court from like the Clean Air Act, climate protections, endangered species protections, you know, so it's a mess. Yeah. And this is why activism and raising awareness of the river and the importance of the river is so key. And, you know, that's why all the measures that people have been taking for decades are important to preserve.
湿地和溪流等其他临时水道的保护可能会受到挑战。这也意味着，各种联邦法规最终都可能闹上法庭，从《清洁空气法》、气候保护到濒危物种保护，所以这是一团糟。是的。这就是为什么激进主义以及提高人们对河流及其重要性的认识如此关键。你知道，这就是为什么人们几十年来采取的所有措施对于保护都如此重要。
Right. And I mean, and those protections start with people actually knowing about their rivers and these waterways. That's where kind of the caring starts of it. And that's where the activism goes from there. Yeah. So yeah,, I know it's not the happiest note to leave this episode on, but you know. We had to tell you, dear listener. We had to tell you. You gotta know. It's important that you know. You gotta know.
对。我的意思是，这些保护始于人们真正了解他们的河流和这些水道。这就是关怀的起点。这也是激进主义由此展开的地方。所以，是的，我知道这不是本集最好的结局，但你知道的。我们不得不告诉你，亲爱的听众。我们不得不告诉你。你必须知道。你知道这一点很重要。你必须知道。
Well, thank you so, so much for reporting the story with us, and thank you for overcoming your fears and getting into a kayak. Oh my gosh. And you can see the LA River. I know you were super worried about that. I am just glad that this podcast does not have a YouTube channel because otherwise Vivian would be showing footage of me just failing at kayaking.
好吧，非常非常感谢你和我们一起报道这个故事，也谢谢你克服恐惧去坐皮划艇。哦，天哪。你可以看到洛杉矶河。我知道你对此超级担心。我只是很高兴这个播客没有YouTube频道，否则维维安就会播放我划皮划艇失败的镜头。
So. You did great. Only for you Vivian and only for 99PI will I get into a kayak. Well, thank you Gillian. Thank you Vivian. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Gillian Jacobs and me, Vivian Ley. Edited by Kelly Prime, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Riel, with additional music
所以。你表现得很棒。为了你维维安，也为了99%无形，我才会去坐皮划艇。好吧，谢谢吉莉安。谢谢维维安。本周的《99%无形》由吉莉安·雅各布斯和我——维维安·莱伊制作。凯利·普莱姆剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里尔配乐，还有额外的音乐
by Mia Byrne. Fact-checking by Graham Hayesha. Special thanks this week to George Wolfe, Eileen Tikada, and Andy Salas. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor, our intern is Nikita Abde. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Christopher Johnson, Lasha Madan, Jaka Maldonado-Medina, Nina Pottsack, Joe Rosenberg, and
由米娅·伯恩创作。格雷厄姆·海沙负责事实核查。本周特别感谢乔治·沃尔夫、艾琳·提卡达和安迪·萨拉斯。凯西·图是我们的执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑，我们的实习生是尼基塔·阿布德。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁比、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉沙·马丹、贾卡·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、妮娜·波特萨克、乔·罗森伯格以及
of course, the boss man, Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered 371 miles and six blocks north of Los Angeles in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our brand new Discord server. There's a lot of nice people talking about architecture and complaining about Robert Moses there. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org.
当然，还有老板罗曼·马尔斯。99%无形标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，现在总部设在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心潘多拉大楼，向北371英里和六个街区。你可以在所有常用的社交网站以及我们全新的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有很多好人，他们谈论建筑并抱怨罗伯特·摩西。在99pi.org上可以找到指向该服务器以及99PI过去每一集的链接。
Okay, I can do this. I can do it. I can do it. Come on baby! Come on baby! I'm getting it! Hello! That was like a level one rapids and it nearly killed me. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，我能做到。我能行。我能行。加油，宝贝！加油，宝贝！我做到了！哈喽！那简直就像是一级急流，差点把我害死。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。